ICO TEHERSILL NOTO
BACK TWORK
HE TED TO EXAIN THATATYBEUSE S O
ILEN A THA AGE CAN EVEGE A VCINE
POST HIS COMAINTIS HE
ISHOCKG.CHESTAANT WHIC
IT PVESHE REHAT NHING
THE DIA. GNG THAPP IN
W TH CARE.HE ISROOF.
ASSE WERCANCELEDFTER THE
ION VOT TO ITCHO REMOTE
ARNG.
EY UHE SAMEXCUSAYIN
TH THEY WE VNERAE.
I SA THEIDS REONESAND
THAT CLDRE ARE COLWHEN
TSID
UNIOS PLANS CAUSAGAI N
POLICIESRE AECTI TM
AND TRE O CHIREN.
WHENHE W RUSEDVI SHE
RAN T O THE STO.
BUYING I CRE THA THE
ESIDT.
OPLEREO SICOF T MASKS
TH'RE GETNG CATIV
MASKHE.NG OUNDOR AUICK
GREAJOB ND
>>ITLE CSE EUGH.
POIN FORREIVITNER CHAE.
AT ITHIS?
ISHATINE?
I'MOINGO ED TT BA.
>>'M N GOING TBLAMTHE
RESTRANT
MEA.YOUREEALI WITTHE
YOUAN'TEJECANYBODYND TAUORITS MR
SPONBILI TDO TS F
YOU COD B FIN.
I THINKHE RTAURT OWNER
OU BE LE TDO WHATER
THEY WT.
IFHEY DON WANYOURIDN
EIR VIOUSLY IS IABOUHETH.
DOT BLAMEHEM.
ITS AT IIS.
KE I SOMEWHE ELSYO AREORRE.
NOW AT T HTERIHA BTH INHE BKSE E
EANGUE APPCIATE TH
JUST DON WANTO GBACK TO
RK
FATES OIOUSLY D'T WT TGOACKOORKE
AMOU OF TE MAHAVE HADT
HOME.
U N'T END AT MUCH ME
AT HOM
THUST JUS WANT  DO OTH
STF BUIT THEERFE
EXSE.
TH CANUST Y EY AAFID STHEYAN'T H
PEOP ARETARTG TO TUR ITS
THE ACHE.
THEYAVA LILE MKERS.S.
THEYUST N'T G PD OUGH
BUT THEYE AUALL MANAGED TOMA THE
TEHER.
NOW EYREOMEH EL. TEACH
AND THE ARTHE IONS
THREENINTO B FR.
A LOT  UNIS A E
DO OWHIS.
HEOU LIKTO S IF W
ULDITHHE RULTS MIG BE.
THIN WHERE TY RERE FM
HAD SEVE BACPAINND THEN
EYAVE DEOSF THEMHEN
EY A POWLIING.
I WLD LE TO SEE THESE
SOMEIDDEN CARA FTAGE I
ULDUANTEEOU-
GUARANT YOU THEREUT ABARS A NH.
SOONS E HODAYSICK IN.
THR SU A DEMAN WIT THESE
REESENTIS SINGHIS.
HOW CH MDRINKI SHEOULD
PAY R U?
IO HAVE AOT OEMPAY.
EN Y THINK A HPENI
ATHE RTAANT.
HE W AA FAY FRCH.
STAUNT.
YOU G THE TO T MISTREED.
WAS TUAL GD THHAPPED.
AS F AS ARG A ESS IT
DN'TORK BECAE IWASN
AN95 DSS